what's going on reject nation rogue
elbow draw so there's a channel that
I've been told by many to check out
especially after doing a video of our
favorite YouTube channels mister crepes
ish we actually watched this guy's video
of the Avengers trailer Justice League
style it's really sweet house he has
this one out Captain America the Winter
Soldier Mission Impossible Fallout style
we're pretty familiar with that trailer
you bet you a reaction to that opening
sketch at the beginning of it how does
it just check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you ready for the world to see you
as you really are
lift the window you know how the game
works
disorder war all it takes is one step
when do we start
[Music]
[Music]
I love that fight
[Music]
[Music]
motorcycles guns I think it's best not
to ask them Benji says it is great if
they really remember that fallout
trailer - to catch all the subtle
references but there's there's plenty of
it - they're like oh that's why he chose
this clip to go over that moment yeah
yeah perhaps whoa this is amazing
editing skills amazing edit and I like
that he doesn't try to take like the
audio of Mission Impossible and throw it
over yeah yeah just just pitches this
movie the exact same way borrowing that
structure and having this song there too
because that moment even working fires
the gun three times yes match like it
gives you little earmarks to work off of
I would imagine yeah yeah each of the
trailer and similar like types of clips
the no not like shot for shot but same
context behind the shot well yeah it
kind of highlights the style too because
like you know Captain America the Winter
Soldier has a sort of espionage II kind
of vibe espionage thriller and Captain
America is also and when our soldiers
when he's questioning the government
Authority and when that's when she'll
gets taken down the Fallout trailer has
Henry Cavill asking him the question of
how many times is this government
betrayed Ethan Hunt you know it's kind
of like Oh crazy a bunch of car chases
yeah we watch the fallout trailer right
before watching this yeah so it's easier
to notice like oh that's how that's
similar that's how they shot similar
even like especially towards the end
like great choice of clips man editing
this is amazing yeah it also highlights
just you know the difference between the
action - yeah and what lends itself to
something like this picture because you
know the two kinds of movies like you
know the Mission Impossible movies the
Marvel movies have both very spectacular
action but in two very different ways
you know so drawing from a different
palette here was interesting and seeing
how they you know worked out what would
match you know between those axes and
stuff is pretty fascinating oh yeah I
mean that's one of the impressive parts
about Winter Soldier I think a lot of
people respect is that there's a lot of
some work and
there's a lot of good fight choreography
in it as well it doesn't rely so heavily
on crazy overblown visual effects and
yeah this is a really good matchup and
yeah I didn't realize like there are
similar things more than just imagery
there's similar things with this
storyline that I didn't register but
prior to go bridle watching this video
so good call man yeah he's gotta go
check out his channel the original video
is linked in the description box mister
crepin shifts KR EPS hu s guys well you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification will get notified
every time one of our videos is up and
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show music video reactions over there
would love to have you as well as weekly
QA yes
you